nothing we just start throwing on the
board we're going like this look it goes
like this
Oh even they're confused the cast of
Avengers endgame trying their best to
put the Marvel movies in chronological
order endgame is the twenty second film
in the franchise but only Kevin was
lucky enough to be on set for the film
that started it all 2008 Iron Man 2
earplugs I don't want to I don't want to
not be able to hear it when someone says
you're on fire this stuff just feels to
me like this is the fantastic summer
camp I never went to you know our first
look at Robert Downey jr. as Tony Stark
we were in the High Sierras and let's
just say our DJ knows how to make an
impression what's he doing he's prepared
for the role
Iron Man hey what's up you see me my
very most butch they say the entrance is
one of the most important things right
here I'm so glad you didn't see me dump
this thing like the [ __ ] man I am here
just avoiding government you by yourself
when a cow TRO landed the role of Pepper
Potts she was injured during filming
yep surgery correct yes I broke my knee
but it's okay as long as I keep sort of
doing my physical therapy and stays okay
is it tough dealing with the kids how do
you do it with when you're hurt like I
spent a long time hopping on one leg
holding my son it was kind of ridiculous
actually
Robert wasn't the first name attached to
Ironman reportedly Nicolas Cage was up
for the part back in 1996 then Tom
Cruise commissioned a script for the
role Hugh Jackman was considered but
director Jon Favreau decided Robert was
the perfect Iron Man figured if I was
ever gonna do one of these kinds of
movies this genre that this would be a
good time to do it before I'm too old
and can't get in shape particularly if
we wind up doing more than one it's
actually two sequels followed not to
mention the Avengers films Ironman
grossed nearly 600 million dollars
modest by today's multi-billion dollar
Marvel Pictures most important this
movie established the Marvel Universe
that has forever changed Hollywood look
I mean he didn't get bit by a spider and
he doesn't have some creepy thing about
bats he's a guy who builds creates and
vents and puts his own ass on the line
with everything he does good luck
keeping on
[Music]
[Applause]